regardez où est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui
je sais pas si vous le savez vous le
voyez pas je mets dans un décor un petit
peu à part on est surtout chez Samsung à
Saint-Ouen c'est joli c'est un tout un
joli port de pêche et aujourd'hui on est
là pour parler de nouveaux téléphones
alors c'est la gamme a fait Samsung qui
vient d'arriver est-ce que vous
connaissez la gamme alors je vous fais
très rapidement c'est dans l'entrée du
milieu de gamme on part du A14 qui vient
d'arriver à 14 4G à 14,5 g il va être
vraiment faire la différenciation entre
les deux modèles pour permettre de tirer
un tarif un peu plus bas avec la version
4G vous avez ensuite le A34 qui arrive
et puis maintenant le A54 qui est le
haut de gamme dans cette gamme là voilà
très clairement donc aujourd'hui on fait
quoi et bien aujourd'hui je vous
présente ces modèles qui sont juste là à
côté de moi à faire le tour complet vous
allez tout savoir pour déjà vous les
présenter puis vous aider à vous
orienter pour savoir quel smartphone
Samsung acheter dans la gamme a
aujourd'hui en 2023 est-ce que vous êtes
prêts parce que moi je suis hyper chaud
je voulais directement allez on y va
regardez alors on va commencer hyper
rapidement je vais vous les montrer on
va se faire un tour complet du design
vous allez voir il y a des petites
différenciations et notamment au niveau
du A14 4G et à 14 ,5 g je vous le
montrer dans le détail mais surtout ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que il se
ressemblent tous ça c'est le nouveau A14
4G ou 5G je sais plus sur 100 mais je
vais vous le montrer voyez ça c'est une
différence entre laquelle j'ai la 5G
vous arrivez ensuite au niveau du hop là
à 34 ici qui est comme ça vous voyez
c'est exactement le même look et vous
arrivez au niveau du A54 donc vous voyez
ils ont vraiment fait un truc c'est
qu'ils ont vraiment voulu complètement
harmoniser la gamme alors harmoniser
avec des petit différence au niveau du
design très léger au niveau du 1 14 4G
il y a 14 5G petite différenciation avec
un dos en verre qu'on va voir sur le A54
5G pour monter en gamme mais sinon ça
raconte à peu près la même histoire au
niveau du design un design qui hérité de
la gamme S donc on reste dans l'idée du
premium dans l'idée du haut de gamme
même si ici on est sur une gamme qui est
forcément un peu moins cher alors je
vous montre ça regardez voilà les A14
alors grosse différence que vous allez
avoir déjà même si vous voyez le design
globalement il se ressemblent la
différence que vous allez avoir ça va
être dans le point de détail est-ce que
vous allez vous en rendre compte là on
est sur des espèces de stries ça fait
des espèces de lignes en fait ça veut
dire que vous êtes sur le A14 4G voilà
c'est vraiment la grosse différence que
vous allez avoir des lignes verticales
en fait ici et on peut sentir que tu es
un peu regardé il chante en fait c'est
un peu comme un côté un peu vinyle ça
c'est la version kg tandis que la
version 5g et bien ça vous fait comme
des espèces de de petits points ça peut
différent en fait je sais pas si vous en
rendre vraiment compte à la caméra c'est
pas très évident mais bon c'est la
petite différence c'est style qu'on va
avoir ici alors moi personnellement je
préfère la version 5G que je trouve un
peu plus fine que la version 4G que je
vais trouver légèrement c'est peut-être
pas le bon terme légèrement un peu plus
grossier mais qui globalement fera le
taf et voyez sinon c'est à peu près la
même chose donc on a dans différentes
couleurs là vous avez la couleur
argentée vous avez également le live
qu'on va retrouver dans les deux
finitions 4G 5G dans les deux modèles 4G
5G puis vous avez le noir qui est le
grand classique qu'on va retrouver
fatalement ici je sais pas d'ailleurs
lequel pourrait vous botter ce qui a une
couleur que vous préférez oui non quoi
comment Mark et bras déjà dans les
commentaires donc ça c'est effectivement
pour ce smartphone au-delà du dos de ce
smartphone vous voyez vous avez 3
caméras ici trois capteurs alors là ce
qu'il faut savoir effectivement c'est
que comme on fait beaucoup aujourd'hui
vous proposer trois capteurs différents
même si vous allez voir globalement il y
en a vraiment un qui va être le plus
intéressant ici vous allez avoir un
grand angle de 50 mégapixels c'est le
capteur principal qui se situe juste ici
au centre là alors il y a une différence
entre la version 4G et 5G sur la version
4G vous avez un ultra grand-angle de 5
mégapixels et sur la version 5G vous
avez une caméra portrait de 2 mégapixels
pour vous tirer un tarif plus
intéressant au niveau de la version 5G
ils ont dû proposer un capteur qui sera
un peu moins officiim donc vous allez
pas avoir deux travaux en temps mais si
vous aimez le portrait bon pourquoi pas
ceci étant dit du portrait de mégapixel
je suis pas extrêmement convaincu et
puis vous avez un capteur macro de 2
mégapixels sur les deux modèles sans
oublier une caméra selfie qui va se
planquer juste à l'avant ici c'est une
tresse mégapixels ok why not pourquoi
pas ce qui nous intéresse maintenant
c'est toute la partie avant avec ce
grand écran ici vous avez une diagonale
de 6,6 pouces que vous savez sur la
version 4G 5G c'est exactement la même
chose alors vous le voyez hein
clairement ici ils ont dû faire des
choix également vous avez un très grand
menton donc ici sur la partie basse et
un contour noir qui est assez proéminin
également sur le reste du smartphone
l'idée c'est que si vous voulez arriver
sur du bord à bord vous allez devoir
ramener vraiment votre écran au bord et
un écran qui va venir légèrement se
plier s'incurer c'est des techno qui
vont coûter fatalement un peu plus cher
et comme ici on vous proposer des tarifs
assez alléchants et les tarifs vous
donne en quelques instants et bien ça me
saoule a dû opérer des choix néanmoins
ici ce qui est intéressant c'est quand
même que vous avez un grand écran pour
venir consommer du contenu à multimédia
alors vous le voyez tout qui peut aussi
être pourquoi pas assez intéressant
c'est que votre caméra elle est inclue
dans une espèce de petite petite bulle
qui vient manger sur l'écran mais ça
vous fait pas un grand truc en plein
milieu de l'écran en gros ça vient un
peu légèrement vous voyez faire une
petite vague ici pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
si c'est un truc qui vous plaît marquez
le moi dans les commentaires ici on est
sur l'écran Full HD plus donc on a une
très bonne résolution donc on est sur un
taux de rafraîchissement de 60 hertz
tout ce qui est plus classique et on est
sur une technologie d'altft voilà comme
ça vous savez tout en plus de ça on a un
haut-parleur mono donc le son sortira
uniquement d'ici et pas de l'autre côté
bon une fois de plus dans cette gamme de
prix c'est pas déconnant côté
performance on tombe sur un médiathèque
hélioger 80 on a 4 Go de RAM 64 Go de
stockage et vous allez voir sur
l'ensemble de la gamme on peut monter
jusqu'à un terrain et le 14 5G il y a un
processeur qui est différent c'est un
médiathèque d'emmène City 700 ici vous
avez 4 Go de RAM mais vous avez le choix
soit 64 Go de stockage soit 128 et une
fois de plus dans les deux cas
extensible jusqu'à un terrain le truc
qui est assez malin que tout a fait
Samsung ici c'est que sur l'ensemble des
produits à 14 4G à 14,5 g à 34 bien
évidemment 5g et à 54 5g et bien ils
nous ont mis des grosses batteries de
5000 millions d'erreurs alors même si
sur les A14 on est sur une recharge 15
watts qui va être pas la plus rapide du
monde mais bon globalement ça vendent
sur des tarifs maîtrisés donc ça a pas
déconnant on va se retrouver sur les A34
et A54 avec toujours cette grosse
batterie de 5000 milliards par heure
mais là pas sur de la recharge 25 watts
c'est un peu plus rapide ça ira alors
les tarifs regardez j'ai pris mes notes
c'est tout noté ici écriture la pâte de
chat donc c'est moi qui vais me faire
plaisir de vous le dire je vais pas vous
le laisser le lire sur le A14 4G on est
à 219 euros ça a vraiment un tarif
maîtrisé chez Samsung pour commencer à
arriver sur cette gamme a et puis si
vous voulez passer sur la version 5G
vous êtes à 249 € alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'il faut aller sur le a14g versus à
14,5 g l'idée c'est que si vous avez pas
pris un abonnement 5g et que aujourd'hui
ça vous sa strictement rien d'avoir un
smartphone 5g de payer un modem 5g et
bien vous allez directement sur le e14g
ça vous permet d'économiser un petit peu
en termes de coût et puis d'abord
ultra grand-angle ça c'est aussi pas mal
alors on les connaît c'est capteur ultra
grand-angle ils vont être bon quand vous
avez beaucoup de lumière dès que vous
manquez un peu de luminosité c'est
toujours un petit peu plus difficile
mais c'est normal une fois de plus sur
des tarifs maîtrisés tout en sachant que
ici en termes de performance on est chez
médiathèque c'est un Hélio G80 ça peut
aller seulement vous parler on est sur
un processeur qui ira très bien pour
tout ce qui va être photo regarder des
contenus multimédia mais des
applications naviguer aucun problème
quelques petits jeux pas trop gourmands
attention ici on va pas trop lui en
demander tout en sachant qu'on a 4 Go de
RAM donc vous voyez on reste vraiment
sur un truc où on y va molo molo et 6 il
y a de stockage c'est pas énorme on peut
en mettre un peu mais pas des caisses
non plus mais après on peut augmenter le
stockage grâce à une carte micro SD qui
va jusqu'à 1 To et ça c'est aussi un
avantage intéressant à noter que
d'ailleurs cette extension de carte
mémoire vous l'avez sur l'ensemble de la
gamme à 14 à 34 à 54 ça c'est cool bon
voilà vous savez quasiment tous sur les
A14 maintenant on va regarder les A34 et
puis bien évidemment juste après les A54
qui probablement pour moi est le plus
intéressant mais fatalement plus onéreux
d'ailleurs si un de ces produits vous
intéresse je vous mets tous les liens en
main dans la description alors que voici
les A34 alors regardez à 34 vous avez
toujours un peu le même design une fois
de plus je vous le dis change pas on a
la couleur noire qui est un très grand
classique chez tous les fabricants
smartphone et c'est globalement celui
qui se vendra le plus parce que c'est
assez neutre et que ça plaît
généralement pas trop mal vous allez
retrouver ensuite la couleur lime Line
qui est plutôt sympa aussi si vous aimez
ce côté un petit peu citron légèrement
verdâtre WHY NOT vous avez ce lavande
qui est très très sympa également assez
doux plutôt joli parce que vous aimez et
on va retrouver l'argent qui alors je
vous le dis tout de suite la seule
différence que vous allez avoir entre
les A34 et A54 au niveau du dos et bien
c'est que pour le A54 l'argenté s'en va
et vous avez un qui arrive et l'autre
différence c'est qu'ici vous avez un dos
en verre là où c'est du polycarbonate en
fait sur les A14 et à 34 c'est un dos en
plastique vous voyez on l'entend on le
sent et l'autre côté vous avez un dos en
verre alors est-ce que vous voulez
réellement du verre on sait pas
d'ailleurs elle est sympa j'ai pas dites
le moi dans les commentaires le vert
prendra les traces de doigts soyons
clairs c'est du vert ça prend les traces
de doigts là où le polycarbonate ne
prendra pas les traces de doigts c'est
pour autant un matériau qui est beaucoup
moins noble bien évidemment c'est du
plastique on va pas se mentir mais bon
voilà une fois de plus sur des tarifs
maîtrisés des tarifs plutôt tirés vers
le bas ça me paraît pas déconnant à vous
de voir Seigneur vous préférez le côté
vert ou le côté polycarbonate vous me
dites bien évidemment dans les
commentaires alors regardez-moi cette
couleur que je vais dire préférée ici
sur ce à 34 alors je trouve plutôt joli
aussi on garde vraiment cette même
design cette même histoire ce que vous
allez voir la différence et là c'est
tout de suite et bien on va avoir un
bord qui sera plus petit par rapport aux
différents à 14 ce sera un peu plus
maîtrisé on va aller un peu plus bas
même si on a quand même un menton qui
est un peu plus grand bien évidemment
vous allez avoir cette petite caméra qui
va être intégrée directement ici ça ça
fonctionne également et on se retrouve
surtout ici avec un écran de 6,4 pouces
Super AMOLED mini 120 alors ici vous
avez vraiment des écrans qui sont
vraiment quasiment similaires entre d'un
côté le i34 ici et le A54 ici différence
que vous allez avoir avec le A54 alors
ça sera le même menton en bas c'est que
votre caméra elle va être inclus
directement ici dans une petite bulle
dans votre écran vous voyez c'est
vraiment la différence principale qu'on
va avoir entre ces deux produits
d'ailleurs je viens d'apprendre que le
dimanche 26 mars c'est l'heure d'été
vous voyez comme ça au moins c'est tout
directement continuer chez Samsung merci
Samsung l'autre différence que vous avez
également c'est la diagonale sur le A34
vous êtes sur une diagonale de 6,4
pouces ok c'est déjà très très grand
soyons clairs ici tandis que sur le A54
on vient monter la diagonale on est sur
6,6 pouces on prend 0,2 pouces
globalement il y a pas une énorme
différence lorsque vous voulez regarder
comme ça il y a pas un truc qui est plus
flagrant si vous voulez mettez deux à
deux vous allez voir que le A34 est un
peu plus grand que le A54 gagne un petit
peu en compacité c'est vraiment la
différence qu'on va avoir ici et dans
les deux cas par contre voyez on a un
pic de luminosité à 1000 Nitz donc un
écran beaucoup plus lumineux donc si
vous allez en extérieur vous avez besoin
de regarder du contenu et bien ça ça va
être vachement agréable et vous êtes sur
les taux de rafraîchissement de 120
Hertz ce qui globalement aussi peut être
plutôt pas mal et commence par ici dans
son variable adaptatif donc vous faites
le choix d'un point de vue logiciel vous
allez avoir soit l'adaptatif vous
laissez votre smartphone gérer
intelligemment switché entre 60 hertz et
120 Hertz soit vous lui dites on va
mettre du 60 hertz alors si vous poussez
du soixantaine sans permanence vous
permettra d'Emmer votre smartphone un
peu plus loin au niveau de l'autonomie
de 120 va consommer davantage mais vous
le laissez faire il est assez malin
parce qu'en plus ici vous êtes sur one
uye on tourne ici sur un Android 13 sur
l'ensemble des modèles donc vous avez la
dernière version d'Android ici que ça
c'est vachement cool également autre
particularité que vous allez avoir entre
d'un côté et votre A34 et votre A54
c'est que vous êtes sur des
haut-parleurs mono alors que je vous le
disais tout à l'heure sur lien 34 à 54
vous êtes sur des haut-parleurs stéréo
alors que sur les A14 vous étiez sur les
haut-parleurs mono d'ailleurs sur un
haut-parleur Bruno il y en avait qu'un
seul et dans tous les cas vous êtes
technologie Dolby Atmos qui est inclus
alors il y a un autre point connaître
c'est la question de la performance sur
ses smartphones là alors regardez une
fois de plus j'ai pris toutes mes notes
sinon tout dit j'ai Samsung donc je fais
plaisir que vous le retransmettre et
bien alors on va se retrouver avec des
petites différenciations sur le A34 vous
êtes sur un médiathèque un dîner City
1080 vous avez soit 6 Go de RAM 128 Go
de stockage soit 8 giga de ram 25 de
stockage dans les deux cas je vous l'ai
dit extensible jusqu'à intérêt ça c'est
vachement cool tandis que sur le A54
vous êtes sur un processeur de la maison
un processeur Samsung c'est un exin
os vous avez pas le choix c'est
d'emblée il y a pas de 6 Go de RAM par
contre vous avez chaud au niveau du
stockage 128 256 et une fois de plus
dans ce cas-là ça monte jusqu'à 1 Tera
alors ce qui nous intéresse ici c'est
toute la partie photo parce qu'on va
beaucoup utiliser son smartphone pour
faire des photos et immortaliser des
moments chouettes alors j'espère qu'ils
sont chouettes sinon on prend pas de
photos parce que on n'a pas envie
d'avoir des souvenirs un peu pourris
vous avez au niveau de votre A34 un
capteur principal c'est un 48 mégapixels
avec une stabilisation optique ça c'est
quand même pas mal vous avez un ultra
grand angle de 8 mégapixels je pense
qu'il est en haut là juste ici et vous
avez un capteur macro de 5 mégapixels
sans oublier une caméra selfie qui est
juste là et ça c'est une 13 mégapixels
alors la différence que vous allez avoir
avec de notre côté ici le A54 c'est que
sur le A54 et bien Samsung vous remet sa
night au graphie la lithographie qu'on
avait connu avec les S22 donc c'est
vraiment l'idée d'avoir une superbe
expérience de photos de nuit d'ailleurs
on en reparlera très très bientôt les
testera ses smartphones donc je vous
invite à vous abonner dès maintenant
comme ça vous saurez absolument tout
mais surtout ici on est sur un capteur
de 50 mégapixels sur le principe c'est
plutôt intéressant avoir bien évidemment
lors des phases de test vous avez un
ultra grand angle de 12 mégapixels on
vient augmenter un petit peu le nombre
de mégapixels par rapport à la version
A34 qui était à 8 mégapixels et puis
vous avez un capteur macro de 5
mégapixels sans oublier une caméra
selfie qui va être un peu plus boostée
ici où vous allez monter sur un 32
mégapixels et alors peut-être que vous
ne connaissez pas et que vous tombez
d'ailleurs juste sur cette vidéo et que
vous me connaissiez pas d'ailleurs je
vous invite à venir vous abonner comme
ça on va se connaître davantage et puis
surtout vous aurez plein d'infos sur la
tech les smartphones les nouveautés des
mondes des tablettes des ordis bref ça
c'est très très cool donc cliquez sur le
bouton rouge si les rouges c'est que
vous n'êtes pas abonné d'ailleurs pensez
aussi à activer la cloche pour notifier
dès qu'une prochaine vidéo arrivera ces
capteurs au niveau de la macro sont bien
évidemment là d'un point de vue
marketing juste pour permettre aux
marques de s'aligner et vous proposer
plein de capteurs parce que à tarif
équivalent s'il y en a un qui a deux
capteurs vous vous direz ah c'est pas
normal pour autant on pourrait se dire
il nous met deux capteurs mais ils vont
mettre un peu plus d'argent dans un
capteur principal dans grand-angle ou
l'ultra grand-angle pour augmenter la
qualité mais aujourd'hui c'est pas le
sujet le sujet c'est de se dire on va
rajouter plus de modèles vous voyez ici
et Samsung fait comme les autres à 14 4G
à 14,5 g à 34 5G à 54 à 5G on vient
moduler la fiche technique au niveau des
capteurs plutôt que vous mettre deux
capteurs et d'être directement plus
booster directement bon ben voilà c'est
normal il faut bien segmenter les gammes
il faut bien proposer plusieurs modèles
pour qu'il y en ait un petit peu pour
tout le monde et une fois de plus rester
concurrentiel par rapport à toute la
concurrence qui vous met aujourd'hui
trois capteurs donc on se retrouve avec
ce tripty grand-angle ultra grand-angle
macro voire mode portrait sur le A14 5G
qui globalement pour moi ne servira pas
à grand chose donc ce qui va vraiment
être intéressant si ça va être le
capteur principal le grand angle c'est
toujours là où les marques mettent la
meilleure capteur pour avoir la
meilleure qualité soyons clairs vous
arrivez sur des smartphones vous allez
voir avec le A14 4G on commence à 219 €
et on monte jusqu'à 549 euros donc plus
on va mettre d'argent et plus on en aura
pour son argent ça me paraît assez
normal pour autant et connaissant le
travail de Samsung sur un 50 mégapixels
sur le A54 5G je ne doute absolument pas
d'avoir de bonnes photos avec mon
grand-angle l'ultra grand-angle
généralement sera un petit peu en
dessous parce qu'ils vont pas mettre le
max de moyens si on veut vraiment aller
le plus loin au niveau de la
photographie aujourd'hui chez Samsung il
faut aller sur la gamme ss23s 23 plus
S23 ultra mais voyons depuis tout dans
la même gamme au niveau des tarifs ça
change un peu l'histoire mais nul doute
et on le verra une fois plus sur ce
qu'on testera parce que j'ai déjà vu
beaucoup de smartphone de Samsung et je
les connais quand même plutôt pas trop
mal tout ce qui va être grand temps que
ça fonctionnera bien évidemment si vous
arrivez sur un tarif un petit peu plus
maîtrisé parce que ça correspond à votre
budget c'est normal vous allez avoir sur
votre a14g ou 5G c'est le grand angle
qui fera le taf l'ultra grand-angle ou
le portrait Macron bon globalement on
s'en fout un petit peu et c'est la même
idée à venir retenir sur le A34 et le
A54 et bien évidemment plus vous allez
mettre de l'argent et plus vous allez en
avoir pour votre argent voilà une fois
de plus soyons clairs là-dessus autre
particularité qui est intéressant sur
les A34 et à 54 c'est-à-dire le A34 là
vous voyez que sur le polycarbonate et
le A54 qu'elle doit en vert qui est
brillant et bien vous avez une
certification
IP67 ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
votre smartphone est certifié par
Samsung est en résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière alors ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il faut aller se baigner avec
et plonger au Cap d'Agde avec votre
smartphone dans la poche non ça veut
dire que s'il pleut s'il rencontre de
l'eau malencontreusement ça va bien se
passer il y aura pas de problème haut et
poussière donc ça c'est plutôt rassurant
pour autant c'est pas là ça c'est
efficace la plus haute la certification
aujourd'hui la plus haute c'est la IP
tout de suite mais on est sur un truc
qui est très cool donc il y a absolument
aucun problème autre particularité qu'on
a cette fois-ci uniquement sur les A54
et bien vous avez la possibilité d'avoir
une ici une carte SIM virtuelle si ça
vous intéresse vous pourrez l'avoir ici
sur le a504 et vous l'aurez pas sur les
autres et autres particularités c'est
que sur le A54 vous allez avoir du wifi
6 alors que ça doit vous envoyer du
wi-fi 5 vous aurez des billes qui seront
un peu moins élevés bien évidemment sur
les a14g à 304 et vous irez plus loin
sur les A4 voilà et si vous voulez après
du wifi 6e faut monter en gamme et aller
un peu plus loin mais clairement de vous
à moi sur un smartphone de la gamme a
Wi-Fi 5 Wi-Fi 6 ça fera le taf je suis
pas sûr que vous ayez besoin d'avoir des
débits de malade et autres infos à
connaître et qui est intéressant c'est
que vous avez sur les A34 et à 54 un
Corning Gorilla Glass 5 qui va venir
protéger toi certifié que votre
smartphone est protégé alors c'est pas
pour autant une certification c'est
vraiment une technologie au niveau du
verre qui va venir le protéger contre
des micro rayures des rayures alors une
fois de plus ici on n'est pas non plus
sur la dernière technologie de Corning
il y a le Gorilla Glass victus plus qui
est sorti mais bon globalement ça ici il
n'y a pas de mauvaise surprise vous
voyez donc bon pas de souci alors bien
évidemment ce smartphone sont
disponibles vous en douterez si je vous
les présente c'est que Samsung vous les
propose et va essayer de vous les vendre
bien évidemment ils veulent que vous
achetiez leur smartphone tout est
constructeurs vols ça donc ça c'est
normal je vous donne les tarifs alors on
va commencer avec le a14g qui a 219 €,
si vous voulez monter sur la version 5g
et bien vous passez à 249 €, il y a 30
balles d'écart donc à vous de voir
vraiment bien évidemment par rapport à
vos besoins à votre budget posez-vous la
question bien évidemment aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez un abonnement 4G
est-ce que vous avez un abonnement 5G si
vous avez un abonnement 4G est-ce que
vous voudrez un abonnement 5G l'année
prochaine peut-être sachez que si vous
achetez un smartphone 4G que vous avez
un abonnement 5g et bien vous n'aurez
pas de 5g vous aurez la 4G il faut le
savoir et ensuite vous passez sur le A34
là vous avez deux configurations 6 + 128
vous êtes à 399 euros et 8 + 256 à 469
euros et puis si vous voulez monter sur
le plus haut modèle avec le plus
d'options le plus de finitions et bien
vous arrivez sur la version 828 à 499
euros et puis la version 8 256 à 549
euros tout en sachant que et ça c'est
intéressant également jusqu'au 30 avril
vous avez une offre de lancement sur les
A34 et à 54 vous allez avoir des
galaxies buzz 2 offert donc si vous
n'avez pas d'écouteur et que vous voulez
des écouteurs de Samsung sont très cool
d'ailleurs je vous avais fait une vidéo
pour vous parler des écouteurs de
Samsung il y a un petit moment peut-être
que je la remette un petit peu à jour et
bien vous allez pouvoir avoir vos Galaxy
buzz profitez d'avoir des petits bouts
de School et de vous balader vous voyez
des complètement dans l'écosystème ça me
saoule avec des écouteurs signés AKG au
niveau du son parce que oui Samsung a
acheté à 4G il y a quelques années donc
voilou donc si un de ces smartphones
vous intéresse et bien une fois de plus
je vous mets tous les liens en bas dans
la description allez jeter un œil alors
bon retour à moi c'est que c'est une
gamme qui est extrêmement intéressante
extrêmement pertinente Samsung reste le
leader du marché il y a une renouveler
leur gamme tous les ans il est évident
que le smartphone ici qui se vendra le
plus et qui marchera mieux c'est le A54
5G c'est toujours un peu le modèle le
plus fort c'est celui où il y a le plus
de volume de vente parce que il propose
des specs super intéressantes vous avez
pas beaucoup de concessions qui sont
faits ça reste un très joli smartphone
l'écran est de très bonne qualité Super
AMOLED vraiment maîtrisée de la part de
c'est Samsung qui fabrique ces dalles
par l'entité Samsung display donc une
fois de plus tout est maîtrisé ici vous
aurez plus un processeur Samsung ici
bref c'est le smartphone 100% Samsung
dans la gamme a les autres sont pas au
reste une fois de plus on vit avec son
budget ce qui est complètement normal
donc s'il y a un de ces smartphones qui
vous intéresse et bien une fois de plus
vous êtes tranquille vous êtes sécurisé
puis il y a d'autres points qui est
vachement intéressant c'est les mises à
jour que vous allez avoir alors je vous
donne une fois de plus au niveau du A14
4G et 5G vous allez avoir 2 ans de mise
à jour de génération de mise à jour au
niveau de l'os donc vous êtes sur
Android 13 vous aurez Android 14 et
Android 15 avec l'expérience logiciel
one why de Samsung qui va avec
d'ailleurs très cool j'en ai déjà parlé
sur ma chaîne allez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil et puis 4 ans de mise à jour de
sécurité donc ça vous êtes quand même
relativement tranquille là-dessus il y a
pas de souci sur les A34 et à 54 vous
avez quatre ans de mise à jour d'Android
Android 15 Android 16 Android 17 Android
18 ça nous emmène quand même
relativement loin et 5 ans de mise à
jour de sécurité donc on a vraiment de
quoi faire et on va aller loin dans le
temps donc c'est smartphone sont très
courts on en reparlera bien évidemment
lors du test probablement notamment dû à
54 dites-moi si vous avez des questions
interrogation
suggestions bien évidemment vous marquez
tout ça dans les commentaires et nous on
se retrouve très bientôt pour continuer
à parler bien évidemment de Samsung mais
pas que de Samsung et se tester
notamment je dis bien notamment ce
Samsung Galaxy A54 5G qui m'a l'air
plutôt très intéressant voilà je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt et puis des bisous moi je vais
aller manger parce que j'ai très très
faim bisous Ciao